today on our show it's not best of 2015
we go through all the movies that we
personally loved right here in the fat
cave on fat pen on Batman which starts
welcome to 2016 man it's the future
happy new year please not with dr. spera
Sonia was in police Adan
like you said dude some of that yes for
our Telemundo watchers man you had good
high school Spanish time to thank you
very much I heard a song or two welcome
to 2016 as you could tell we wear the
same [ __ ] in 2016 pretty much that we
were in the last days of 2015 there
lived in yeah but that's okay not every
year starts a new adventure kids
sometimes the years just run into one
another and well because ottoman all
sameness we're going to look back on the
year that was and so it made sense to
wear the same clothes we were wearing
the last year we saw you hire this man
to write a Buffy like TV show ladies and
gentlemen he's so [ __ ] smart you [ __ ]
Buffy like
update your reference hire this man to
write a daredevil type of TV show or a
flash type TV show either either one
okay so we're gonna go over our favorite
movies of 2015 so disclaimer that
doesn't mean these are the best movies
of 2015
no these this means at least on my list
I can't speak for mark but I'm sure mark
will probably back this up these are the
movies of all the movies I saw in 2015
of which were a lot they well actually
when I looked at it not much I think
it's crazy when I went through the list
of like [ __ ] that I saw this year
because I entered movies 2015 and on the
Wikipedia page they gave me a full list
of like all the movies that came out
this year so I went through every month
and like if I saw the movie I wrote it
down then I broke that list down into a
piece of my favorites list and stuff and
you know I didn't I didn't see a whole
[ __ ] ton well you were in maker mode a
little bit of maker mode but yeah I'm
not gonna say like it wasn't a great
year for movies because there was a lot
of wonderful movies but there wasn't a
lot calling out to me I guess is what
I'm saying
maybe I'm getting old yeah man but I
like that [ __ ] Marvel movies so it's
like you know there's some stuff there
in the middle
I know like early summer that I missed
that I wanted to see but didn't like I
really wanted to see spy and missed it I
liked it yeah I like spice but I was not
on my top ten list but I saw him and
enjoyed it Paul fake name fake five you
think maybe we'll say Kevin Feige Paul
fake I don't see good director knows how
to do his [ __ ] comedy chops men and
she's hysterical [ __ ] I'd watch her
tell me I'm untalented like she's so
[ __ ] God maybe she's like don't laugh
I'm being honest well well do any other
word for you can't help it you're
hysterical
she's funny man I'll [ __ ] she's she's
great but that I saw that it's not on my
like top-10 list but I really enjoyed
that movie I saw that but not in the
theater I don't know like stream on
iTunes or something with the wife so you
know there's a lot of like here when I
looked at the list dude ex machina came
out in [ __ ] January yeah
so since January I just finally watch
two days ago since January I've been
seeing his movie gone like oh my god I
don't see that movie and I didn't
[ __ ] see it until like two days ago
and it's been out forever man look at
this incredible flick Alex garland made
man reminded me of was that TV show like
black black mirror see black mirror kiss
wasn't the best TV on TV much blending
I'm gonna like [ __ ] give it the time
come on dude it's happened a long time
ago live peak tattoo that I'm my [ __ ]
body we're putting on my headstone must
be live [ __ ] stamp yeah okay so what
we're gonna do is look at of all the
movies we did see movies we liked the
most so that's not [ __ ] gone like if
you don't [ __ ] agree with us your
dick hey movie watching is very
subjective kiss you may be a dick but
it's not because you didn't agree with
ain't gonna be because of this I'll tell
you there's no causality you're a dick
if you put a [ __ ] string around
kittens next and push them down the
sewers
you're a dick I read
welcome capillary lessons school scared
I was like this happens I think it was
in an Upton Sinclair or something of
course it was where I was like oh my god
the inhumanity to gods Falana jungle by
upton sinclair kind of sad but in any
event then you're a dick if you don't
agree with our list or conversely we
don't agree with your list this was more
what i'm getting at that doesn't make it
dixie again there's no dicks here no
this is just some [ __ ] we like some [ __ ]
we saw some [ __ ] we like paid for all
this [ __ ] so we can say what we liked
and we're not gonna sit around and be
like [ __ ] we did [ __ ] like and just
because something in the top 10 done
mean that we didn't like we did not make
a worse list no cuz who needs that and i
didn't see everything for example
hateful eight is not on this list
because i'm seen it yet so i can't tell
you whether there you go so yes we're
not very good at this
we'll make a date for the roadshow yeah
we're just telling you I've seen X Mac
into two days ago around Thanksgiving up
next year no I'm gonna watch that soon a
[ __ ] I'm gonna make time for a quick
Willy because the 70 million big
experience give him a single [ __ ]
preach just like Marx talking about his
dick just thing used to measure dicks by
right like that's a word they basically
invented just to measure dicks earth six
types yes have to be no nobody says like
oh what's the girth of that pipe maybe
they don't the proper use of girth bill
is live - scared of nails are they
working on the house I don't know the
doors don't work alright so here we go
kids this is 2015 we'll start from the
from 10
did you put yours in order I did let's
go number four numbers so you'll do 10
and then I'll do 10 now we've got a lot
of the same movies but a different
position we do so with we've waxed
eloquently
number nine for something that's nine on
my
that's like three on yours we want them
get to three and be like oh my god here
we go you totally go back and what we
said seconds ago
well no will get a letter going like
Hello it was really lazy there you guys
just reiterate your points Jesus all
right so let's go from mom let's begin
with number 10 all right what's your
number 10
my number 10 listen you show me yours
okay all right my number 10 is Kingsman
what the Secret Service good dude
honestly I didn't even I forgot that
movie came out wasn't even on my
February so you'll get to it right or
something but I saw it I like that movie
quite a bit [ __ ] I might have to
reconsider remind me at the end of this
let me see if I drop anything off my
list what do you think you know I hate
to say this is shitty but like I might
have to knock the peanuts movie a little
boy inside of me just died a thousand
deaths going like you used to love us
and now you still be here the adult
what's that you'd rather watch a movie
with a lady of [ __ ] knife legs I
guess that's your prerogative sir he's
my little red-haired girl but number 10
for you yeah I mean I just I didn't give
him a single I didn't expect much from
the Kingsmen despite the fact that I
like I like Matthew Vaughn as a
filmmaker
hmm I love Colin Firth he didn't know
that Taran a John McCain all caring for
Colin Firth Karen fish I love Karen
first Colin Firth's less-popular is so
Mark Darcy yes for all time and he's
such a wonderful actor and he was really
[ __ ] he's great Big E he was the
[ __ ] thing they sold this movie on
yes the knife e feet and the [ __ ]
guns and [ __ ] but he was the epitome of
cool matt matter manners maketh the man
who's [ __ ] you know almost
steel Avengers stick John and steel type
[ __ ] you know attack with a bowler
and a [ __ ] umbrella yeah it was very
user a John Steed wants tea that's acid
steel
Danielle Steel all right so I had so
much fun with this movie like it Sam
Jackson Sam Jackson doing a lisp as a
villain and having the time of his life
my last one of his better performances
of the last five years I love that he
will he will almost do anything and he's
said this it's like if you if you let me
do something I've never done before I
will say yes to your movie
he made some weird movie and Finland
when they just let him be the present
manager why they let him be the
president okay there's a good movie too
it's none of that movie but he's having
a blast Matthew Vaughn is having a blast
making this thing it's like a James Bond
movie that is based there's this
wonderful like Westboro Baptist Church
it's so much fun kill sequence where
it's just like you know look in a world
where you know you could pull that off
we were talking about last episode like
hey man if they get this right they
could do martial law based on Kingsman
alone yes you do martial law like the
ultra violence in the movie and how it's
played and also like one of the
predicating like third act [ __ ] like
I hope either hero wins is a girl gone
if you do it like I could have anal I'll
let you put it in the ass come on a
sense of Denmark or something like do
you know what really irritated me about
that fact that someone else did that I
should have done that yeah it was a fun
flick a very lad type flick as they say
only but a fun flick super fun like
really smart really just you know it had
so much just joy to it you know the way
you don't see lots of movies of that
like magnitude Mark Millar Craig yes
indeed Mark Millar and and what's his
Matthew Vaughn make a good good pair
indeed he did kick-ass kick-ass as well
all right amber 10 my number 10 was the
big short which I might you know oh well
here the big sure it gets on my list
because I think Adam McKay is a really
good filmmaker and I didn't realize it
until I just watch this movie yeah like
you know of course you always associated
him with like Will Ferrell movies and
stuff like that and they're funny I mean
that takes [ __ ] accountable that [ __ ]
off as movies do Barry
well but this is kind of like and not
like you know he's out from behind
[ __ ] Will Ferrell and [ __ ] like that
I understand he helped with ant-man as
well and it looks like he might be
helping with a mentos but as a filmmaker
dude I'm like I was [ __ ] stunned at
how how talented the man was the chops
he put on display for a movie that like
I didn't read the book but come on man
math numbers finance like subprime
mortgages oh how do you make that work
and [ __ ] who get rich like off of the
mistakes of the system like none of that
should be interesting to me it's not in
my matrix but Adam McKay found a way to
[ __ ] pull it all together and when he
needed humor he leaned on it nicely not
overly heavily particularly when you had
a very complicated concept to explain to
the audience he would be like here to do
that is and it was like some famous
actress or [ __ ] some weird Anthony
Bourdain or some such [ __ ] clever like
just kept you dialed in enough for [ __ ]
that like you know when I was a kid
there's that moment in trading places
where you're like I'm laughing but I
don't know what I'm laughing at like why
is orange juice funny like explain to me
how buying orange futures movie always
baby feel dumb as a kid where I was like
I'm just gonna laugh because it's Eddie
Murphy ah ah Forbes literally had to do
an explainer to explain how the end of
that movie works it's so good no it's
like what's happening they're buying low
and selling high in their bite what what
they won but how how did they win I'm
happy they won but did they win I don't
know it is absolutely the management
stuff by that point in the movie if
you're not invested in those two guys it
didn't land a gorilla this well there's
nothing just except for all that bad
which is always a good totally like all
right [ __ ] my giant gorillas all right
big short well made well acted across
the boards man you got Christian Bale
just being as as Bailey as possible in
terms of like he gets lost in the
[ __ ] character really great
performance where's the mortgage yeah
he's [ __ ] pretty tremendous in this
by getting props like he believed he's
this kind of on the spectrum
he's an eyes like a kind of lazy eye oh
how they do that in movies like do you
think that's an actor thing where you're
like I'm acting with my eye I bet you
for him it is like yeah they're like we
can give you a lens easy [ __ ] mind
give me like two weeks come back with
[ __ ] eyes could be great
he's pretty fantastic in the movie give
that dude a nod man like he's really
good you know let's kid deserves a nod
no he's not on my list Trumbo do you see
Trumbo yeah good movie but John Goodman
and Trumbo is probably my [ __ ]
favorite performance of the year and he
has a line about being in the movie
business where I was like stood up in
the house it was so good but anyway
jumping back performances in this movie
and Big Short wonderful not just
Christian Bale Ryan Gosling who always
gives you know I mean look this people
some women like him so he's adorable
[ __ ] kids a genius actor yeah he's
like well he's DeNiro [ __ ] genius
like you watch him like Jesus creepy
genius
Steve Carell who is very character II
and does a good job and who's the fourth
dude it's another Oh [ __ ] Brad Pitt
this is so good in this movie dude so
underplayed I'm telling you I'm Akay
he's [ __ ] like I'm not like he's
arrived like he's been here he don't
well many many years but I'm like my
it's not even like my esteem jumped I
was like Jesus this guy's like my better
I didn't realize this guy was [ __ ] my
battery my saw my steam to jump hugely
that it's not like the subject matter
and that's why it's number 10 on my list
so like Kingsman could knock it off just
by virtue of the fact that it's a fun
remember memorable movie and stuff I
don't remember much about the subject of
big short like the may I couldn't
[ __ ] tell you how it happened just
like Trading Places has baffled and
teary-eyed at the end but the
performances the filmmaking put it on my
list as a movie to be seen and [ __ ]
respected instead all right is
definitely worth your time but it's a
it's a [ __ ] math movie kid
a lot of numbers and [ __ ] I haven't seen
it so I can't speak to it no over here
I'll if your favorite number 69 not the
numbers movie alright that was my number
10 what's your number 9 my number 9
documentary ooh I've got a documentary
on my list I've got one on my list too
so
Helen Netflix's what happened mr. mom I
didn't see it how is that it's beautiful
it's heartbreaking it is I mean it's a
story of Nina Simone who was a sort of
R&B soul singer in the in the 60s and
70s who was famously bipolar oh really
yes so like she would swing high and
swing low she was abused by her husband
she had alcohol and drug problems but
made the most amazing art it's one of
those stories of like do you have to be
broken to make great things because this
woman was fundamentally shattered by
both life and by circumstance and by
where she ended up in her life and and
one of the voices in this documentary is
her daughter who grew up with this who
grew up with her mother swinging between
like suicide and ecstasy and and
watching her sort of retell living with
that it's heartbreaking
it's all heartbreaking but the music is
so great
um and it's so great I think it's
garbage day and that's what you want a
documentary you know you want to watch
something that takes you deep inside the
soul of somebody else or inside the life
of somebody else where you can get
emotional because we see ourselves
reflected in whatever we're watching
stuff but then it allows you would get
out points as well
so I think we dig those depressing
documentaries or documentaries about the
real because people deal with that a lot
of people like depressing dude it's my
[ __ ] life like I am like her blah
blah I have to live with somebody's like
that but well made who made it - now Liz
Garbus is the director and it's yeah and
it's also about this this woman this
black woman in the 60s who was not
conventionally attractive in any way so
you've got like The Supremes in one
corner and the Nina Simone over here and
even like a wreath of Franklin over
there but trying to build a career when
she wanted to write songs about civil
rights weren't dry songs about what it's
like being black and ugly
at a time when people a trying to say
the black is beautiful but she's not and
B people are fighting for civil rights
people are dying in the street and the
sort of wars that she had with like
record labels and to a certain degree
even with with her audience of this is
my art and my art has to be Who I am and
right now I'm a black woman in 1965 who
cannot go to certain parts of the
country I've got a fleet of Paris in the
way that artists always have of color
for you know a century to I'm going to
find myself in Paris like jazz became
popular in Paris before it became
popular here because they were cold
Libertines it's all fine but yeah dude
it's just it's so deep and it's so
heartbreaking about music that I knew
but didn't know very much about who was
making it well my number 9 is gonna see
him real [ __ ] his dog and he's he's an
underdog and his dog is better than him
and he's bald know the sentimental favor
for me I can't be nearly as eloquent
about the peanuts movie as you just were
about now I want to see that talking big
bill and I got a screen or at home so
he's on Netflix on the Netflix too you
can watch it for [ __ ] free for
nothing kids every penny so I love the
peanuts moved by virtue of the fact that
boy you want to talk about true the
source material you know we're all going
not so force awakens because it's Star
Wars and because it's very close to the
source material this peanuts moving man
it's like Charles Schulz made it it's so
close to the source material apparently
he's said in his will before he died
he's like he can't create any new stuff
without me so this was based on like an
old idea that he'd had and stuff but
they ain't got anymore so this was it
and boy for there may be only at bad I
mean I guess they can kind of do other
like they should just remake grace for
your life Charlie Brown what a great
idea
I [ __ ] love them or better than that
[ __ ] Snoopy come home Oh cuz that's
got all the feels man do you
of sick girls in hospitals there's no
way in a world where Marley and me made
money Snoopy could home in this style
would make a billion dollars dogs dying
children the hallmarks of great cinema
box-office um I enjoyed the movie like
crazy because I was a big Snoopy family
I was a kid huge to be fed and they were
true to the characters ain't no cell
phone in this peanuts movie ain't no
iPad in this peanuts movie right now is
like well then why would I possibly
watch the point can I watch it on my
iPad no I saying that it's cut all ties
with the modern they churned butter in
this movie when your school bell rings
pull the cord and the kids call run into
one room and watch the peanut there's a
cotton gin
I saw a boy with the dog I saw him
turned to his father and say father why
his father said history my my number
eight it is that Star Wars movie
all right on man stone this comes in a
number it comes in a number eight we've
got the image up in cases listen there
and we talked at length about Star Wars
more than once
oh yeah they're only will for the next
year yeah but you know our feels on it
and my vote is simply because of fields
because of the fields that I have for
the charge in my spine yeah well you're
not sitting there going like this guy
[ __ ] reinvented cinematic who are you
telling
no you're saying this guy made a fun
[ __ ] movie yeah you know and if you
if you choose to find problems with Star
Wars you can like they're there yeah but
you know for my money and there is no
better moment for me this year no better
movie moment and when that lightsaber
flies through the air into resin to
raising I'll meet you I got you beat me
beam on one moment better than that
you think I'm [ __ ] and when chewy
[ __ ] and [ __ ] whips out the laser
crossbow and spoilers gut shoots kylo
Ren that may pie I hope when when I die
and hopefully I'm still in this business
and they put me up but maybe that's the
only time I'll ever get to the Oscars
like hey finally [ __ ] died when they
show supposed to be like me is Silent
Bob or some [ __ ] thing I did in
movies I'm gonna request they don't show
that just show that scene just
associates good feelings of vengeance
with me as my favorite moment of movies
[ __ ] I saw it again for third time the
other night and [ __ ] I yelled out loud
that's what would happen dude like well
as a writer if you always want to you
know take your material to the to a
place where people who I identify with
you always gotta ask yourself the
question what would really happen you
know what I'm saying like what would
really happen don't just [ __ ] make up
[ __ ] like the [ __ ] Russian mobs what
would really happen
that's what would really happen if
[ __ ] his boy if a big space dogs
friend got killed and they were friends
for like 40 years and [ __ ] like that he
would scream and he would try to [ __ ]
kill the dudes son who was the one who
tried to create him get care he's the
cop he didn't give a [ __ ] he stabbed Han
he's just I hate this emo oh [ __ ]
against boys like that there were there
were enough moments that made me feel
like I was nine years old again then
that's why it still makes my list
nice mine also stars Oscar Isaacs and
the guy who played general Hux domhnall
gleeson yes those name that is his name
ex machina which I just finally saw came
out in January we talked about it before
man good [ __ ] flick
credibly well done very low-budget from
what I understand it's like basically a
two-hander the most sometimes the three
hander but Oscar Isaacs do is my
favorite actor of the year like he's
wonderful in the force awakens and he's
wonderful in this book he's [ __ ]
fantastic in ex machina he's the star
and that's saying something because the
girl who plays Ava whose name I don't
know ELISA of the Kunder well done is
like a giant walking talking special
effect because she's the robot lady you
seen the posters wonderful performance
but he's I believe that guy exists Oscar
Isaacs scientist character is more real
than real and he don't play it like you
know I'm a scientist
he's [ __ ] dude who happens to be
brilliant like goodwill heavy dose it's
the Elon Musk's it's the very
approachable it's oh I just so gonna be
brilliant yes
I just love dancing in onesies and and
the whole movie you sit there going like
am I being played is he being played
it's about a kid who gets brought up to
a billionaires estate to test an AI
robot and they talk about the Turing
test I guess which is Alan Turing Tory
yeah who was in the movie come from
Gaucho movie last year without him we
don't win the whoops I'm down the
imitation game the war is not one yeah
we don't we don't win the war the Brits
don't win they don't crack the cipher
the Enigma machine as we learned from
movies Indian maybe a little bit history
it's Alan Turing guy he was very smart
so touring there's a Turing test which I
guess that's what you test a computer
with to tell if it's artificial
intelligence or not or whatever then
comes to avoid contests later on we're
just like you see a turtle what do you
do turtles I down my mother turtle what
shoot a [ __ ] moment they start
asking me about turtles and mothers I'm
not lazy crossbow this kid goes to test
this AI this robot if you will and
interesting things start happening
there's shades of many pieces of classic
sci-fi it's not a no monitor movie where
it's like oli took that he took that but
you know there's elements great sci-fi I
mean once you know there's enough of
like these sort of Isaac Asimov the
Three Laws of Robotics and all that
stuff they're automatically just sort of
or you're gonna be like hey Blade Runner
for a minute and then be like oh no not
Blade Runner like it's more movies way
smarter than that
right so I I put that at number eight
and most people have seen it by now if
you haven't check it out yes okay number
seven number seven I got I got to be
some Steve Jobs right on I just I can I
represented on your list listen I am
such a in the bag Aaron Sorkin fanboy
you go with all the shows I like sports
night I like sports night
I love the west wing then west wing is
my [ __ ] jam really I have now seen
the west wing soup-to-nuts beginning to
end four times and every election is
just like wow I had the other day on
Twitter I spent a good hour just
concocting a westering reunion special
that'll never happen but that I wanted
you happy though oh god you have no idea
dream dude it can happen Steve Jobs
didn't do that well so maybe Aaron
Sorkin's like that I need some money
please something fast what was gonna
make it some move fast look uh West Wing
reunion there's a guy on Twitter so I
saw Steve Jobs and I enjoyed it but it
didn't make my top ten list it's
something of a magic trick of a movie in
as much as it's a play yeah absolutely
use just a play like it's and I'm not
saying that I'm to diminish to like to
diminish it I enjoy it but it's not know
that it's not dramatic in the way that
we want things to be dramatic in a movie
in a movie bus if you like dialogues
porn oh god dude it's just it's
beautiful stuff and it's it's set around
these three separate product launches
and so basically it's it's a chamber
drama yeah where it's you know Steve
Jobs and his assorted
sort of Apple support staff and his I
guess ex-girlfriend and his daughter all
there before the launch of the original
Macintosh the next in like 1993 and then
in 1996 or 7 or something like that but
it's all this behind-the-scenes drama of
how this guy why this guy and wanted you
know found himself poised to redefine
technology as we know it and how
technology in his head could affect
society and make our lives better but
he's a fundamentally broken man like
there's a line where he just says I'm
poorly made and he realizes that and so
it charts both his mania as well as his
relationship with his daughter and how
getting to admit to parentage getting to
admit to the joys that eventually would
come with fatherhood is where he begins
to kind of crawl out of this sort of
self-involved mania that had defined his
life for so long I mean fast benders
great Kate Winslet who plays his little
amazing performance yeah even even
[ __ ] Rogen's really great Kogan's
great in there yeah the guy who plays I
can't remember his name because he's
just so good bozniak Rogen plays Wozniak
there's another guy who plays another oh
yeah he was really great too it was
really show him him poster yeah and the
young woman who played his daughter was
Bibi in Kill Bill get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah could Paul dude I was looking
at that movie when I was because I
watched it in a theater I paid to see
that in theater and then I watched the
Oscar screen it was my wife and I
remember watching that scene go and she
looks familiar and I went to fall down
the rabbit hole of like who is she on
IMDB and I didn't do it but now that you
say it instantly I'm like oh my god
you're like I saw her she did an
audition tape for Jersey girl back in
the days really your father was quite a
shooter too he shot it he shot this
scene with the kid where she having like
a Dalek scene with Ben Affleck at his
character and like he shot it in such a
way where I was they can eat directly
just really much I was like she's not
ready she's too young but their fathers
a hell of a shooter yeah Wow
but like as a writer and as somebody who
kind of loves structure yeah watch
somebody break so much of those rules of
drama but still make you care and still
because it's all about the Sorkin words
and it's all about like the speed and
the pace and that the weird thing where
he does well he'll set up an idea and
then diverge from it for a while and
then circle
back around and just pin that idea in
the astrovan yeah you start to cry again
you dig that I dig that man I am he he
well look he's way more successful than
I have ever been will ever be but he and
I get accused the same thing which is
all of our characters sound exactly like
us that's the thing I watch The Steve
Jobs and I was like I was like watching
not so much Steve Jobs as it is watching
Aaron Sorkin because every character
sounds like Aaron Sorkin which is fine
by me because I like the writing of
Aaron Sorkin yeah I mean I watched like
all of studio 60 on the Sunset Strip
which is a shitty television show you'll
dig it but you know like every now and
again there will be a thing in it where
my god damn it Aaron Sorkin I love you
bye that was your seven that was my
seven my seven was the gift tell me
about the gift if there's a good movie
directed by Joel Edgerton who's actually
in the movie and I think he wrote it -
hmm so this is in this guy this is you
know Joel Edgerton is I do yes uncle
Owen from the prequels
that's what Joel Levinson is now he
directed a movie better than anything
I've [ __ ] made this is crazy man yeah
he's got the Edgerton the it's it's a
real like Twilight Zone II kind of
affair in terms of like you know what
you do comes back to haunt you that's
not really Twilight Zone at all I'm not
describing I'm not nearly as eloquent as
Mark and you [ __ ] know I don't even
want to finish the show just watch that
documentary gift is really [ __ ] good
did you get great job writing great job
directing Jason Bateman [ __ ] ran into
with the movie theater yesterday when I
went to see force awakens when I turned
around I saw him and like I'd seen that
dude he's like my most awkward celebrity
sighting in my life because generally
like he's seen a lot of famous people in
this town but I never like interact with
him that much but I was at a Bob fresh
and he was at a Baja fresh eating by
himself and I was like oh man like I
don't want to be that guy but like I
[ __ ] I love I love him going back to
Silver Spoons me and [ __ ] the show
that he had after that the two of us
whatever the [ __ ] and but so I was a fan
going way back
you know and and then Arrested
Development massive [ __ ] kind of
Michael Bluth so I was like do I do it
do I do it and I was like pocket all
right now went over I was it came in I
hate to do I give the same [ __ ] line
that people give to me like hey not
getting to do this but like I'm a huge
fan and he was the very so he's like oh
thanks man and I don't know if he was
just like hey you're that guy he's kind
of look at music thanks went back to his
meal nice [ __ ] dude years later man
like the other night I want to see the
force awakens and I turned around I saw
him again and I was like hey hey and he
looked at me hey and I don't know again
if he was just like lift up from the
burrito okay every time you get away
from a burrito but I don't know if he
knows who the [ __ ] I am other than oh
that's the guy and he seems very
enthusiastic to see me I do I'm so
receptive when I see that guy Mikey's
talented my weirdest celebrity encounter
yeah I was in an elevator at Comic Con I
want to say like three years ago with my
buddy Adam who's Jewish this is only I'm
only saying because this brings the
story not just your bread and we're in
this elevator and Christoph Waltz it
gets any elevator nice and my friend
literally just like tightened up
daughter and I have like the best time
ever
my friends just like sweating it's like
be Druze I don't mind my friend it's not
like he asked his friend for like a cup
of milk or something like that but it
was just like I don't know why but that
guy is there it makes me fear from my
relatives what did I just see him oh I
watched half a Spectre the other day he
was in some of it that I saw I didn't
get to all the meaty part you watch I
haven't seen Spectre yeah I still have
and then something happened so I was
like I'm gonna go do something else but
I got to finish it and stuff but I like
that he's a thing mm he's his own
cottage industry now they're the
Christoph Waltz of it all seems like a
good actor all right man let's get to
five then we'll split it up what was
that but that was seven that was seven
so were six so now we're on six what do
you got I got it man do you yeah no a
man didn't make my listen I really liked
it oh good
I did not expect much from a man every
basic
every every one of these weird like
offbeat movies and Marvel puts out I
well this will be the one that breaks
the street yeah
this will be the bad idea that they have
I get first I thought guardians was a
bad idea I also thought a man was like
it's a [ __ ] man really that's right man
and I gotta get it I get it like it's a
smaller movie than the other movies it's
not about but it's Iron Man it's it's
Iron Man but he's not trying to save the
world right he's just trying to like be
a good dad yeah you know and like as a
person who tries to be a good dad like
that just hit the sweet spot for me and
it's heist movie and I love heist movies
Peyton Reed yeah wonderful job directing
the flick as everyone on the line knows
that go right at one point was gonna be
the director so he had to step in a big
shoes of a guy that didn't make the
movie but rooms large in the film arts
Peyton Reed I thought did a wonderful
job
imminently watchable movie I've seen
this movie I saw it once in the theaters
but I've seen it now three times since
then on planes and on home video and
stuff it's so watchable you know it
should have been on my top 10 and
[ __ ] Michael Pena gave one of my
favorite you might kill yeah yeah yeah
it was like the MVP of that movie for my
kid he's retired from with me for for
John with John Goodman from the in terms
of best yeah performance of the year
because it's so easily could have been
like a caricature it so easily could
have been some weird insensitive we're
gonna do the like high-pitched Latino
guy that we gangster light but so much
[ __ ] hard and just such a good time
and just little touches like you know I
like to Shiraz I wish that was on my
list I should have put it on my list man
I have Mad Max fury road in that spot
Mad Max in your list I do indeed tell me
where Mad Max fury road man up come on
[ __ ] I don't have to found up the
pitch for this [ __ ] movie god no I'm
gonna find a camera I don't have to
pitch for this movie kids want a George
Miller a 70 year old man go look at your
grandpa or your mom and and see my mom's
70 I looked at her the other day I was
like why didn't you make that
you're 72 number one that's a [ __ ]
accomplishment and of itself number two
like to go back to your [ __ ] source
material and like do it even better than
you did it when you were a young block
incredible man is a wonderful [ __ ]
flick even if you don't give a [ __ ]
about the Mad Max Universal um be honest
I wasn't one of those guys I'm not I'm
not a crazy like [ __ ] bad backs and
road warrior like you know they were
fine I saw him at MIT but not you've
seen my movies you never hear me like
referencing those afflictions without a
touchdown for you my big touchdown Somme
appreciate them but not like that was
not my jam and stuff this movie
absolutely my gym that's so good this
movie is makes you Union give a [ __ ]
about the other ones man you're like
this is it and I'm in it's crazy good
excellent filmmaking it's winding up on
a bunch of like you know critics group
yeah like the toddlers review like as
reckless film as kind of nuts and
reminds me of like a Blade Runner II
kind of affair and not the movie itself
but you know as a movie that didn't do
that well the box office did nothing
didn't but it didn't do you know a
killer business but everybody respects
that everybody [ __ ] loves it and
stuff seems to be a new high standard in
terms of not just making an action movie
but making you know a well made thinking
person's action movie and it's also just
like it is so unique in so many ways
that it feels like there's no way this
would have been a Warner Brothers movie
like it is so just rambunctious Lee
creative in a way that usually gets the
edge of sand down in the studio system
what you want to do here's we're gonna
do you guys I swear giant [ __ ] car
huge speakers dude with a guitar
flamethrower
suspended to this thing hard guitar we
can do this right the leg is not the
main character he's like no you see him
for a sec but that guy we've got to
figure out how to do this they're guys
are boba fett the moment we put him in a
movie nobody gives a [ __ ] about anything
else let's just always talk about
Minnetonka and like in the same way that
one of the things that that we've
responded to about Star Wars was they
built this [ __ ] like they built a
Millennium Falcon they're walking on
that
there are dudes on sticks doing 60
through the desert [ __ ] doing the
SIRT distillation like it is amazing how
much that counts for something like the
best guy was there that guy almost
killed himself to do this thing for my
enjoyments crazy you're right makes you
appreciate it just a little bit more
like where you're like well I know
that's not CG yeah so my god crazy these
guys went to [ __ ] Namibia with 75 cars
doing 60 miles an hour blowing [ __ ] up
for me what did what did give me a
single what the [ __ ] did you do when you
went not what the seven-year-old man I
said to my mom - Isaac you went in the
midea why didn't you make Mad Max mind
your 70 anywhere in the midea you had a
selfie stick you could have done so
that's our first
that's our 10 through 6 that's our 10
through 6 so if they come back to the
next episode
give us a two-shot next episode you come
back we'll do our top five five four
three two and one but just to recap
before we leave my number 10 is to make
sure that you're number 10 was Kingsman
watch him bolt my number 9 was the
peanuts movie here's was what happened
miss Simone both valid my was ex machina
yours star wars force awakens
mmm-hmm my number seven I can't even
count backwards was the gift
what is your Steve Jobs my number six
was Mad Max fury road and yours was man
oh so far worthy list anybody who's
[ __ ] like [ __ ] you guys you hadn't
seen movies these were good movies are
totally ain't no well then we had some
classy [ __ ] with marks documentary don't
say it's all like Marvel Marvel Zombies
and [ __ ] like that yes we are but we
also like classy classy [ __ ] and as a
preview I have a documentary in my top
five and I'm less classy we'll finish
our list me and Mark here on fat man
Batman talking about our favorite movies
of 2015 we use that superlative best so
you know favorite it on the ones we
enjoyed the most this is the [ __ ] we
love hopefully you love this too don't
forget there's always a podcast to
listen to go to SModcast comm don't
forget to subscribe to the channel tell
all your friends
we love doing this so we're gonna keep
doing it as long as people are watching
them [ __ ] and we're watching those
subscriptions rise it's magic um what
else come back next episode we'll give
you the rest of the list
bring it where's that besides sounds
more of a threat than to.com slash Kevin
Smith there it is Batman I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith
Mark Barnard we'll see you next time
same bat time same bat Channel and that
is as Mark said yeah you too bad cop
sighs Kevin Smith pee pee poop you
hey Nance meet Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder